mr. secretary-general
mr. president world leaders and
distinguished delegates welcome to New
York it is a profound honor to stand
here in my home city as a representative
of the American people to address the
people of the world as millions of our
citizens continue to suffer the effects
of the devastating hurricanes that have
struck our country I want to begin by
expressing my appreciation to every
leader in this room who has offered
assistance and aid the American people
are strong and resilient and they will
emerge from these hardships more
determined than ever before
fortunately the United States has done
very well since election day last
November a the stock market is at an
all-time high
a record unemployment is at its lowest
level in 16 years and because of our
regulatory and other reforms we have
more people working in the United States
today than ever before
companies are moving back creating job
growth the likes of which our country
has not seen in a very long time and it
has just been announced that we will be
spending almost 700 billion dollars on
our military and defense our military
will soon be the strongest it has ever
been for more than 70 years in times of
war and peace the leaders of nations
movements and religions have stood
before this assembly like them I intend
to address some of the very serious
threats before us today but also the
enormous potential waiting to be
unleashed we live in a time of
extraordinary
breakthroughs in science technology and
medicine are curing illnesses and
solving problems that prior generations
thought impossible to solve but each day
also brings news of growing dangers that
threaten everything we cherish and value
terrorists and extremists have gathered
strength and spread to every region of
the planet rogue regimes represented in
this body not only support terrorists
but threaten other nations and their own
people with the most destructive weapons
known to humanity Authority and
authoritarian powers seek to collapse
the values the systems and alliances
that prevented conflict and tilted the
world toward freedom since World War two
international criminal networks traffic
drugs weapons people force dislocation
and mass migration threaten our borders
and new forms of aggression exploit
technology to Menace our citizens to put
it simply we meet at a time of both
immense promise and great peril it is
entirely up to us whether we lift the
world to new heights or let it fall into
a valley of disrepair we have it in our
power should we so choose to lift
millions from poverty to help our
citizens realize their dreams
and to ensure that new generations of
children are raised free from violence
hatred and fear this institution was
founded in the aftermath of two world
wars to help shape this better future it
was based on the vision that diverse
nations could cooperate to protect this
of
preserve their security and promote
their prosperity it was in the same
period exactly 70 years ago that the
United States developed the Marshall
Plan to help restore Europe those three
beautiful pillars their pillars of peace
sovereignty security and prosperity the
Marshall Plan was built on the noble
idea that the whole world is safer when
nations are strong independent and free
as President Truman said in his message
to Congress at that time our support of
European recovery is in full accord with
our support of the United Nations the
success of the United Nations depends
upon the independent strength of its
members to overcome the perils of the
present and to achieve the promise of
the future we must begin with the wisdom
of the past our success depends on a
coalition of strong and independent
nations that embrace their sovereignty
to promote security prosperity and peace
for themselves and for the world we do
not expect diverse countries to share
the same cultures traditions or even
systems of government but we do expect
all nations to uphold these two core
sovereign duties to respect the
interests of their own people and the
rights of every other sovereign nation
this is the beautiful vision of this
institution and this is the foundation
for cooperation and success strong
sovereign nations let diverse countries
with different values different cultures
and different dreams not just coexist
but works side-by-side on the basis of
mutual respect strong sovereign nations
let their people take ownership of the
future and control their own destiny and
strong sovereign nations allow
individuals to flourish in the fullness
of the life intended by God in America
we do not seek to impose our way of life
on anyone but rather to let it shine as
an example for everyone to watch this
week gives our country a special reason
to take pride in that example we are
celebrating the two hundred and
thirtieth anniversary loved'
Constitution the oldest constitution
still in use in the world today this
timeless document has been the
foundation of peace prosperity and
freedom for the Americans and for
countless millions around the globe
whose own countries have found
inspiration in its respect for human
nature human dignity and the rule of law
the greatest in the United States
Constitution is its first three
beautiful words they are We the People
generations of Americans have sacrificed
to maintain the promise of those words
the promise of our country and of our
great history in America the people
government the people rule and the
people are sovereign I was elected not
to take power but to give power to the
American people where it belongs in
foreign affairs we are renewing this
founding principle of sovereignty our
governments first duty is to its people
to our citizens to serve their needs to
ensure their safety to preserve their
rights and to defend their values as
president of the United States I will
always put
America first just like you as the
leaders of your countries will always
and should always put your country's
first
all responsible leaders have an
obligation to serve their own citizens
and the nation-state remains the best
vehicle for elevating the human
condition but making a better life for
our people also requires us to work
together in close harmony and unity to
create a more safe and peaceful future
for all people the United States will
forever be a great friend to the world
and especially to its allies but we can
no longer be taken advantage of or enter
into a one-sided deal where the United
States gets nothing in return as long as
I hold this office I will defend
America's interests above all else
but in fulfilling our obligations to our
own nations we also realize that it's in
everyone's interest to seek a future
where all nations can be sovereign
prosperous and secure America does more
than speak for the values expressed in
the United Nations Charter our citizens
have paid the ultimate price to defend
our freedom and the freedom of many
nations represented in this Great Hall
America's devotion is measured on the
battlefields where our young men and
women have fought and sacrificed
alongside of our allies from the beaches
of Europe to the deserts of the Middle
East to the jungles of Asia it is an
eternal credit to the American character
that even after we and our allies
emerged victorious from the bloodiest
war in history we did not seek
territorial expansion or attempt to
oppose and impose our way of life on
others instead we helped build
institutions such as this one to defend
the
Rinty security and prosperity for all
for the diverse nations of the world
this is our hope we want harmony and
friendship not conflict and strife we
are guided by outcomes not ideology we
have a policy of principled realism
rooted in shared goals interests and
values that realism forces us to
confront a question facing every leader
and nation in this room it is a question
we cannot escape or avoid we will slide
down the path of complacency numb to the
challenges threats and even wars that we
face or do we have enough strength and
pride to confront those dangers today so
that our citizens can enjoy peace and
prosperity tomorrow if we desire to lift
up our citizens if we aspire to the
approval of history then we must fulfill
our sovereign duties to the people we
faithfully represent we must protect our
nation's their interests and their
futures we must reject threats to
sovereignty from the Ukraine to the
South China Sea we must uphold respect
for law respect for borders and respect
for culture and the peaceful engagement
these allow and just as the founders of
this body intended we must work together
and confront together those who threaten
us with chaos turmoil and terror the
scourge of our planet today is a small
group of rogue regimes that violate
every principle on which the United
Nations is based they respect neither
their own citizens nor the sovereign
rights of their countries
if the righteous many do not confront
the wicked few then evil will triumph
when decent people and nations become
bystanders to history the forces of
destruction only gather power and
strength no one has shown more contempt
for other nations and for the well-being
of their own people than the depraved
regime in North Korea it is responsible
for the starvation deaths of millions of
North Koreans and for the imprisonment
torture killing and oppression of
countless more
we were all witness to the regime's
deadly abuse when an innocent American
college student otto warmbier
was returned to america only to die a
few days later we saw it in the
assassination of the dictators brother
using banned nerve agents in an
international airport we know it
kidnapped a sweet 13 year old japanese
girl from a beach in her own country to
enslave her as a language tutor for
North Korea's spies if this is not
twisted enough now North Korea's
reckless pursuit of nuclear weapons and
ballistic missiles threatens the entire
world with unthinkable loss of human
life it is an outrage that some nations
would not only trade with such a regime
but would arm supply and financially
support a country that imperils the
world with nuclear conflict no nation on
earth has an interest in seeing this
band of criminals arm itself with
nuclear weapons and missiles the United
States has great strength and patience
but if it is forced to defend itself or
its allies we will have no choice but to
totally destroy
North Korea rocket man is on a suicide
mission for himself and for his regime
the United States is ready willing and
able but hopefully this will not be
necessary that's what the United Nations
is all about that's what the United
Nations is for let's see how they do it
is time for North Korea to realize that
the denuclearization is its only
acceptable future the United Nations
Security Council recently held two
unanimous 15 - nothing votes adopting
hard-hitting resolutions against North
Korea and I want to thank China and
Russia for joining the vote to impose
sanctions along with all of the other
members of the Security Council thank
you to all involved but we must do much
more it is time for all nations to work
together to isolate the Kim regime until
it ceases it's hostile behavior we face
this decision not only in North Korea it
is far past time for the nations of the
world to confront another reckless
regime one that speaks openly of mass
murder vowing death to America
destruction to Israel and ruined for
many leaders and nations in this room
the Iranian government masks a corrupt
dictatorship behind the false guise of a
democracy it has turned a wealthy
country with a rich history and culture
into an economically depleted rogue
state whose chief exports are violence
bloodshed and chaos the longest
suffering victims of Iran's leaders are
in fact its own people rather than use
its resources to improve Iranian lives
it's oil profits go to fund Hezbollah
and other terrorists that kill innocent
Muslims and attack their peaceful Arab
and Israeli neighbors this wealth which
rightly belongs to Iran's people also
goes to shore up Bashar al-assad's
dictatorship fuel Yemen Civil War and
undermine peace throughout the entire
Middle East
we cannot let a murderous regime
continue these destabilizing activities
while building dangerous missiles and we
cannot abide by an agreement if it
provides cover for the eventual
construction of a nuclear program
the Iran deal was one of the worst and
most one-sided transactions the United
States has ever entered into frankly
that deal is an embarrassment to the
United States and I don't think you've
heard the last of it
believe me it is time for the entire
world
to join us in demanding that Iran's
government end its pursuit of death and
destruction it is time for the regime to
free all Americans and citizens of other
nations that they have unjustly detained
and above all Iran's government must
stop supporting terrorists begin serving
its own people and respect the sovereign
rights of its neighbors the entire world
understands that the good people of Iran
want change and other than the vast
military power of the United States that
Iran's people are what their leaders
fear the most this is what causes the
regime to restrict internet access tear
down satellite dishes shoot unarmed
student protesters and imprison
political reformers oppressive regimes
cannot endure forever and the day will
come when the people will face a choice
will they continue down the path of
poverty bloodshed and terror or will the
Iranian people return to the nation's
proud roots as a center of civilization
culture and wealth where their people
can be happy and prosperous once again
the Iranian regime support for terror is
in stark contrast to the recent
commitments of many of its neighbors to
fight terrorism and halt its finance in
Saudi Arabia early last year I was
greatly honored to address
the leaders of more than 50 Arab and
Muslim nations we agreed that all
responsible nations must work together
to confront terrorists and the Islamic
extremism that inspires them we will
stop radical Islamic terrorism because
we cannot allow it to tear up our nation
and indeed to tear up the entire world
we must deny the terrorists safe haven
transit funding and any form of support
for their vile and sinister ideology we
must drive them out of our nations it is
time to expose and hold responsible
those countries who support and finance
terror groups like Al Qaeda Hezbollah
the Taliban and others that slaughter
innocent people the United States and
our allies are working together
throughout the Middle East to crush the
loser terrorists and stop the
reemergence of safe havens they use to
launch attacks on all of our people last
month I announced a new strategy for
victory in the fight against this evil
in Afghanistan from now on our security
interest will dictate the length and
scope of military operations not
arbitrary benchmarks and timetables set
up by politicians
I have also totally changed the rules of
engagement in our fight against the
Taliban and other terrorist groups in
Syria and Iraq we have made big gains
toward lasting defeat of Isis in fact
our country has achieved more against
Isis in the last eight months than it
has in many many years combined we seek
the de-escalation of the Syrian
and a political solution that honors the
will of the Syrian people the actions of
the criminal regime of Bashar al-assad
including the use of chemical weapons
against his own citizens even innocent
children shock the conscience of every
decent person
no society could be safe if banned
chemical weapons are allowed to spread
that is why the United States carried
out a missile strike on the airbase that
launched the attack we appreciate the
efforts of the United Nations agencies
that are providing vital humanitarian
assistance in areas liberated from Isis
and we especially thank Jordan Turkey
and Lebanon for their role in hosting
refugees from the Syrian conflict the
United States is a compassionate nation
and has spent billions and billions of
dollars in helping to support this
effort we seek an approach to refugee
resettlement that is designed to help
these horribly treated people and which
enables their eventual return to their
home countries to be part of the
rebuilding process for the cost of
resettling one refugee in the United
States we can assist more than 10 in
their home region out of the goodness of
our hearts we offer financial assistance
to hosting countries in the region and
we support recent agreements of the g20
nations that will seek to host refugees
as close to their home countries as
possible this is the safe responsible
and humanitarian approach for decades
the United States has dealt with
migration challenges here in the Western
Hemisphere
we have learned that over the long term
uncontrolled migration is deeply unfair
to both the sending and the receiving
countries for the sending countries it
reduces domestic pressure to pursue
needed political and economic reform and
drains them of the human capital
necessary to motivate and implement
those reforms for the receiving
countries the substantial costs of
uncontrolled migration are borne
overwhelmingly by low-income citizens
whose concerns are often ignored by both
media and government I want to salute
the work of the United Nations and
seeking to address the problems that
cause people to flee from their homes
the United Nations and African Union led
peacekeeping missions to have invaluable
contributions in stabilizing conflicts
in Africa the United States continues to
lead the world in humanitarian
assistance including famine prevention
and relief in South Sudan Somalia and
northern Nigeria and Yemen we have
invested in better health and
opportunity all over the world through
programs like PEPFAR which funds AIDS
relief the president's malaria
initiative the global health security
agenda the Global Fund to end modern
slavery and the woman entrepreneurs'
finance initiative part of our
commitment to empowering women all
across the globe we also thank
we also thank the secretary-general for
recognizing that the United Nations must
reform if it is to be an effective
partner in confronting threats to
sovereignty Security and Prosperity too
often the focus of this organization has
not been on results but on bureaucracy
and process in some cases states that
seek to subvert this institution's noble
aims have hijacked the very systems that
are supposed to advance them for example
it is a massive source of embarrassment
to the United Nations that some
governments with egregious human rights
records sit on the UN Human Rights
Council the United States is one out of
193 countries in the United Nations and
yet we pay 22 percent of the entire
budget and more in fact we pay far more
than anybody realizes the United States
bears an unfair cost burden but to be
fair if it could actually accomplish all
of its stated goals especially the goal
of peace this investment would easily be
well worth it major portions of the
world are in conflict and some in fact
are going to hell but the powerful
people in this room under the guidance
and auspices of the United Nations can
solve many of these vicious and complex
problems the American people hope that
one day soon the United Nations can be a
much more accountable and effective
advocate for human dignity and freedom
around the world in the meantime we
believe that no nation should have to
bear a disproportionate share of the
burden militarily
or financially nations of the world must
take a greater role in promoting secure
and prosperous societies in their own
regions that is why in the Western
Hemisphere the United States has stood
against the corrupt destabilizing regime
in Cuba and embrace the enduring dream
of the Cuban people to live in freedom
my administration recently announced
that we will not lift sanctions on the
Cuban government until it makes
fundamental reforms we have also imposed
tough calibrated sanctions on the
socialist Maduro regime in venezuela
which has brought a once-thriving nation
to the brink of total collapse the
socialist dictatorship of Nicolas Maduro
has inflicted terrible pain and
suffering on the good people of that
country this corrupt regime destroyed a
prosperous nation by imposing a failed
ideology that has produced poverty and
misery everywhere it has been tried to
make matters worse Maduro has defied his
own people stealing power from their
elected representatives to preserve his
disastrous rule the Venezuelan people
are starving and their country is
collapsing their democratic institutions
are being destroyed this situation is
completely unacceptable and we cannot
stand by and watch as a responsible
neighbor and friend we and all others
have a goal that goal is to help them
regain their freedom recover their
country and restore their democracy I
would like to thank leaders in this room
for condemning the regime and providing
vital support to the Venezuelan people
the United States has taken important
steps to hold the regime accountable we
are prepared to take further action if
the government of Venezuela persists on
its path to impose authoritarian rule on
the Venezuelan people we are fortunate
to have incredibly strong and healthy
trade relationships with many of the
latin-american countries gathered here
today our economic bond forms a critical
foundation for advancing peace and
prosperity for all of our people and all
of our neighbors I ask every country
represented here today to be prepared to
do more to address this very real crisis
we call for the full restoration of
democracy and political freedoms in
Venezuela
the problem in Venezuela is not that
socialism has been poorly implemented
but that socialism has been faithfully
implemented
from the Soviet Union to Cuba to
Venezuela
wherever true socialism or communism has
been adopted it has delivered anguish
and devastation and failure those who
preach the tenants of these discredited
ideologies only contribute to the
continued suffering of the people who
live under these cruel systems America
stands with every person living under a
brutal regime our respect for
sovereignty is also a call for action
all people deserve a government that
cares for their safety their interests
and their well-being including their
prosperity in America we seek stronger
ties of business and trade with all
nations of goodwill but this trade must
be fair and it must be reciprocal for
too long the American people were told
that mammoth multinational trade deals
unaccountable international tribunals
and powerful global bureaucracies were
the best way to promote their success
but as those promises flowed millions of
jobs vanished and thousands of factories
disappeared others gamed the system and
broke the rules and our great middle
class once the bedrock of American
prosperity was forgotten and left behind
but they are forgotten no more and they
will never be forgotten again while
America will pursue cooperation and
commerce with other nations we are
renewing our commitment to the first
duty of every government the duty of our
citizens this bond is the source of
America's strength and that of every
responsible nation represented here too
day if this organization is to have any
hope of successfully confronting the
challenges before us
it will depend as President Truman said
some 70 years ago on the independent
strength of its members if we are to
embrace the opportunities of the future
and overcome the present dangers
together there can be no substitute for
strong sovereign and independent nations
nations that are rooted in the histories
and invested in their destinies nations
that seek allies to be friend not
enemies to conquer and most important of
all nations that are home to Patriots to
men and women who are willing to
sacrifice for their countries their
fellow citizens and for all that is best
in the human spirit in remembering the
great victory that led to this body's
founding we must never forget that those
heroes who fought against evil also
fought for the nations that they loved
patriotism led the polls to die to save
Poland the French to fight for a free
France and the Brits to stand strong for
Britain today if we do not invest
ourselves our hearts and our minds in
our nations if we will not build strong
families safe communities and healthy
societies for ourselves no one can do it
for us we cannot wait for someone else
for faraway countries or far-off
bureaucracies we can't do it we must
solve our problems to build our
prosperity to secure our future or we
will build vulnerable to decay
domination and defeat the true question
for the United Nations today for people
all over the world
who
for better lives for themselves and
their children is a basic one
are we still Patriots do we love our
nation's enough to protect their
sovereignty and to take ownership of
their futures do we revere them enough
to defend their interests preserve their
cultures and ensure a peaceful world for
their citizens one of the greatest
American patriots John Adams wrote that
the American Revolution was affected
before the war commenced the Revolution
was in the minds and hearts of the
people that was the moment when America
awoke when we looked around and
understood that we were a nation we
realized who we were what we valued and
what we would give our lives to defend
from its very first moments the American
story is the story of what is possible
when people take ownership of their
future the United States of America has
been among the greatest forces for good
in the history of the world and the
greatest defenders of sovereignty
Security and Prosperity for all now we
are calling for a great reawakening of
nations for the revival of their spirits
their pride their people and their
patriotism history is asking us whether
we are up to the task our answer will be
a renewal of will a rediscovery of
resolve and a rebirth of devotion we
need to defeat the enemies of humanity
and unlock the potential of life itself
our hope is a word and world of proud
independent nations that embrace the
duties seek friendship respect others
and make common cause in the greatest
shared interest of all a future of
dignity and peace for the people of this
wonderful earth this is the true vision
of the United Nations the ancient wish
of every people and the deepest yearning
that lives inside every sacred soul so
let this be our mission and let this be
our message to the world we will fight
together sacrifice together and stand
together for peace for freedom for
justice for family for humanity and for
the Almighty God who made us all thank
you god bless you god bless the nations
of the world and god bless the United
States of America thank you very much